FIVE."
"SPECIAL REPORT" IS UP NEXT.
>> Bret: A GOOD EVENING, I’M
BRET BAIER.
A NEW SURVEY INDICATES EIGHT IN
TEN AMERICANS ARE WORRIED THAT
FEWER REGULATIONS WILL MEAN MORE
INFECTIONS.
MEANWHILE THE PROCESS
PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLS THE
TRANSITION TO GREATNESS ROLLS ON
WITH CONSIDERABLE SUPPORT ON THE
GROUND.
BUT THERE COULD BE HANG HANG UP
ON THE NEXT ROUND OF
CONGRESSIONAL ASSISTANCE.
CHIP CORRESPONDENT JOHN ROBERTS
STARTS US OFF TONIGHT ON THE
NORTH LAWN.
>> JUST A FEW MINUTES AGO
PRESIDENT TRUMP REVEALS THAT HE
WILL GO OFF OF HIS DOSING OF
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE ON FRIDAY,
WHICH WOULD MARK 14 DAYS SINCE
THE LAST CASE OF CORONAVIRUS WAS
IDENTIFIED IN THE WEST WING.
IF THERE HAVE BEEN NO NEW ONE
SINCE THEN.
AND WHILE THE PRESIDENT’S FEUD
WITH THE STATE GOVERNMENT OF
MICHIGAN CONTINUES HE JUST
COMPLETED A MUCH MORE
CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOGUE WITH A
BIPARTISAN DUO OF GOVERNORS.
IN THE CABINET ROOM TODAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP MEETING WITH THE
GOVERNORS OF ARKANSAS AND
KANSAS.
BOTH STATES IN THE EARLY STAGES
OF REOPENING.
>> President Trump: STATES ARE
OPENING UP, SOME RAPIDLY AND
SAFELY AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
THAT AND I THINK WE WILL GET
BACK AND HAVE SOME VERY GOOD
NUMBERS I WOULD PROJECT.
I THINK WE WILL HAVE A GREAT
TRANSITION.
>> THE TRANSITION IS ON DISPLAY
IN FLORIDA WELCOMING
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE AND
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS GOING
OFF ON THE MEDIA.
>> YOU HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
YOUR PROFESSION WHO WHACKS
POLITICALLY FOR WEEKS AND WEEKS
ABOUT HOW FLORIDA WAS GOING TO
BE JUST LIKE NEW YORK.
WAIT TWO WEEKS.
WHAT WE ARE EIGHT WEEKS AWAY
FROM THAT AND IT HASN’T HAPPENED
HAPPENED.
>> WITH ALL 50 STATES AND SOME
DEGREE OF REBOOTING A NEW
ASSOCIATED PRESS POLL FINDS THAT
83% OF RESPONDENTS WORRY THAT
RE-OPENINGS WILL LEAD TO NEW
INFECTIONS IN THEIR AREAS.
BUT SUPPORT FOR CONTINUED
RESTRICTIONS OF SLIPPING.
69% OF RESPONDENTS NOW
SUPPORTING A BAN ON GATHERINGS
OF MORE THAN TEN PEOPLE COME
DOWN FROM 82% LAST MONTH.
BUT AS STATES OPEN UP MORE
OVERSEAS TRAVELING TO BE SOON
CLOSED.
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE SINGH
NEW TRAVEL BANDS MAY BE IMPOSED.
>> WE ARE WATCHING VERY
CAREFULLY WHAT’S TAKING PLACE IN
SOUTH AMERICA INCLUDING BRAZIL.
IT WAS A SIGNIFICANT SPIKE IN
CASES AND PRESIDENTS MADE IT
CLEAR THAT WE ARE CONSIDERING
ADDITIONAL TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP TODAY AGAIN
LASHING OUT AT THE GOVERNMENT OF
MICHIGAN, THIS TIME TWEETING
THAT THE SECRETARY OF STATE HAD
MAILED OUT ABSENTEE BALLOTS TO A
7.7 MILLION PEOPLE CLAIMING THIS
WAS DONE ILLEGALLY AND WITHOUT
AUTHORIZATION BY A ROGUE
SECRETARY OF STATE.
AFTER JOCELYN BENSON’S OFFICE
SAID IT WAS MAINLY BALLOT
APPLICATIONS AND NOT ACTUAL
BALLOTS, THE PRESIDENT REVISED
HIS TWEET BUT CONTINUED TO
INSIST IT WAS ILLEGAL TO WHICH
BENSON REPLIED, POPPYCOCK.
>> THE CARES ACT ENABLED US AND
MY COMIC COLLEAGUES IN SEVERAL
STATES TO MAIL THOSE OUT.
>> THAT COMES AS MICHIGAN IS
DEALING WITH ANOTHER CRISIS,
EXTENSIVE FLOODING FROM TWO DAMS
I COLLAPSED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD NOT SAY
WHAT FUNDS WOULD BE WITHHELD NOR
WHAT HE THOUGHT WAS ILLEGAL
THOUGH IT’S CLEAR HE OPPOSES
MASS MAIL IN BALLOTS.
>> President Trump: MAILING
BALLOTS ARE VERY DANGEROUS.
TREMENDOUS FRAUD INVOLVED IN
TREMENDOUS ILLEGALITY.
>> ESTABLISHED CASE LAW HAS
FOUND IT’S ILLEGAL FOR LOCAL
CLERKS TO SEND OUT UNSOLICITED
BALLOT ABSENTEE APPLICATIONS
ALTHOUGH IT’S POSSIBLE THAT SHE
COULD CLAIM BECAUSE SHE’S MAILED
THEM TO ALL 7.7 MILLION
REGISTERED VOTERS IN THE STATE
OF MICHIGAN AND THERE COULD NOT
BE ANY HINT OF BIAS.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE CASES THAT
COULD BE WELL DECIDED WITH A